[Music]
these are real laws for example in Santa
Fe New Mexico you could be cited for
appearing in public wearing less than 11
pounds of turquoise jewelry in
Mississippi there is an I in team
because Jesus wants it that way in
Kansas if you went at the airport until
your seat mate
we're not in Oz anymore every passenger
on the plane gets to open hands slap you
in Trenton New Jersey it's a one
thousand dollar fine to say wait this is
the capital of New Jersey in Texas it is
permissible to refer to bullets as gun
berries in Hollywood California your
driver's license must include the name
of your improv team in Morgantown West
Virginia it's illegal for people to
bing-bong Mima inner outhouse in Hawaii
there's a fine if you can't play the
ukulele version of somewhere over the
rainbow while wearing a fedora if you're
a passenger on the crosstown bus in
Atlantic City New Jersey you must
purchase an extra ticket for your oxygen
tank in Atlanta Georgia it's illegal for
a street named Peachtree to intersect
with a street that's not also named
Peachtree
in Hermosa Beach California it's a
$5,000 fine for a bra to be in
possession of one or more worries in
Williamsburg Brooklyn if you are
attending a regular-season adult
kickball league game and you're fidgets
spinner falls into someone's matcha
almond milk latte you must obtain verbal
consent before turning the entire
incident into a charming tale at an
upcoming moth storytelling slam not cool
buddy not cool you just lost a fan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in Silicon Valley California if an
officer pulls you over you're legally
required to tell them about the app
you're developing in Birmingham Alabama
it's illegal for a man to get a
lower-back tattoo
unless it says exit only and finally in
Washington DC it is illegal for the
president oh who the hell are we kid
[Applause]
you